so 2022 was quite the year here's
Bloomberg's two minute Roundup in
January the Federal Reserve laid the
groundwork to raise rates to tackle the
fastest inflation in a generation adding
to Global inflationary pressures
Russia's invasion of Ukraine the attack
began in late February and dominated
headlines from the destruction on the
ground to U.S sanctions on Russian Banks
and oligarchs by March attention zeroed
in on the specific threats that Russia
posed restricting the flow of natural
gas to Europe and attacks near a nuclear
power plant in Ukraine corporate drama
started to pick up in April when Elon
Musk made a 43 billion offer to take
Twitter private while Netflix reported a
loss in subscribers and changed his
strategy to embrace advertising the
theme in May Market Mayhem as the FED
boosted the size of its rate hike to
half a percentage Point sending U.S
stocks to 13-month lows while a single
Trader at Citigroup made a mistake that
sparked a flash crash in European stocks
recession fears took root in June half
the headlines of Bloomberg's 10 most
read stories that month featured the r
forward another r word row after the
Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade
geopolitics were the big stories over
the summer the killing of former
Japanese prime minister Shinzo Abe and
Nancy Pelosi defined China when she
visited Taiwan the UK lost its longest
serving Monarch in September two weeks
later the new prime minister unveiled
unfunded tax cuts that caused the pound
to crash in October Credit Suisse became
a meme stock setting new lows as some
retail investors bet the bank would go
bust
while Xi Jinping Consolidated his power
adding more loyalists to China's
leadership crypto winter arrived in
November when FTS collapsed
destabilizing the industry and by
December Bankers were tallying up the
cost from slumping markets sparked by
the fed's rate hike campaign their
wallets will take a hit as Wall Street
firms prepare to slash year-end bonuses
[Music]